[Música]
ser bisexual lesbiana gay trans es una
orientación así como el tipo de cabello
con el que naciste tu tono de piel tu
color de ojos pero también puede ser un
gusto así como el tipo de música que
decides escuchar las películas que
prefieres ver incluso las personas con
las que te juntas es un gusto una
preferencia y una orientación pero
muchas veces no se entiende esto así que
yo por eso decidí educar acerca de este
tema mi hermano de 10 años sobre lo que
es pertenecer a la comunidad lgtb le
expliqué a un niño de 10 años lo mejor
que pude acerca de lo que es ser gay
cuando termine de explicarle me volteo y
me miró y me dijo pero es necesario que
a mí me gustan los hombres porque la
verdad a mí me gustan mucho las mujeres
a lo que yo volteé le dije que a mí
también me encantan las mujeres donde no
hay problema y no es necesario que te
gusten los hombres sólo porque conozcas
del tema a ustedes también muchos de
ustedes estarán preguntando vaya pero
porque le estás enseñando este tipo de
temas a un niño de 10 años
pues porque a lo largo de mi vida de mi
educación he pasado por diversas
experiencias que la verdad no quiero que
mi hermano haga pasar a otras personas
mi transcurso por la secundaria
mis compañeros me hicieron varias cosas
las que eran mis compañeras que yo creí
que eran mis amigas cuando hacíamos
formación y teníamos que pues obviamente
poner el hombro tocar el hombro de tu
compañero de enfrente
muchas decían de que hay no hubo porque
me toca porque la lesbiana me está
tocando de seguro y es porque le gustó
está enamorada de mí quiere hacer algo
conmigo no no no no no
viena no me toques para ponerlos en
contexto en esos tres años yo no había
dicho que era bisexual porque soy
bisexual no lesbianas son cosas
distintas
y las mujeres no se quedaron sólo con
eso también los chicos hicieron mucho
muchas cosas
escudándose en este tipo de comentarios
que de seguro todos han escuchado o al
menos los que somos de la comunidad de
'la es que eres lesbiana porque no has
conocido un verdadero hombre por eso te
gustan las mujeres pero vas a ver que ya
una vez que me conozcas a mí se te van a
olvidar que te gustan las mujeres usando
este tipo de comentarios se escudaban y
decían y hacían acciones que pues son
deplorables como besarme a la fuerza
toquetear me e incluso intentaron hacer
otro tipo de acciones que por las cuales
pudieron haber ido a la cárcel
y ustedes muchos dirán bueno porque no
le pediste ayuda a un profesor porque
muchos profesores al presentarse este
tipo de casos no saben cómo reaccionar
simplemente ven a un joven distinto con
preferencias distintas y dicen ok es
distinto hay que tratarlo distinto uno
una de mis experiencias que ahorita pues
ya lo acepte ya en cierto punto hasta me
puedo reír de ella de la absurda que fue
es de que uno de mis profesores de
educación física era de pasen las niñas
y hagan una fila como pueden ver yo soy
una niña que me gustan las niñas no me
convierte en hombre ok y pues ahí va yo
le voy a hacer fila y decía tú no ana tú
no regresa te
y después mandaba a llamar los niños se
formaban los niños y luego decía ok
ahora los sexos no definidos pasen y me
hacía pasar a mí formarme al fin
de las dos pilas en medio para pasar por
toda la secundaria y que todos pudieran
apuntar de ahí va la lesbiana y miren
esa chica le gustan las chicas se va a
ir al infierno de seguro
y esto es más común de lo que ustedes
creen según investigaciones el 55% de
de los compañeros que rodean a un joven
niño o incluso un universitario adulto
tienden a estigmatizar y discriminar a
su compañero solo por tener una
orientación o preferencia distinta a
ellos el 40% lo acepta y con acepta me
refiero a que lo ignora eso no es
aceptación y sólo un 5% lo incluye esto
viene diciendo que si tú tienes 100
compañeros en tu salón solo vas a tener
5 amigos que te incluyen porque
pobrecito no tiene amigos porque es gay
y no solo está este acoso también está
la violencia correctiva que pues por lo
que dice el nombre es la violencia la
violación que se hace para
corregir al joven que tiene sus
preferencias y orientaciones distintas a
las comunes
este acto a mí se me hace deplorable
porque nadie tiene el derecho a cambiar
un aspecto fundamental del ser humano
con violación es algo que simplemente no
debería pasar y qué
pues que simplemente con eso tú ya estás
perdiendo tu humanidad porque estás en
serio intentando que una persona se
vuelva más humano y normal haciendo
cosas deshumanizadas eso no es posible
en mi cabeza eso no cabe la verdad y
también está esto de qué
ya cuando pues lo aceptas muchas
personas claro que te van a discriminar
te van a insultar y al momento de estar
yo haciendo la investigación para poder
pararme aquí darles esta plática
descubrí que la cnv a la comisión
nacional de derechos humanos dice que en
tres meses se asesinan a 594 personas
se imaginan ese número de personas
asesinadas solo y lo especifican por
pertenecer a la comunidad lgtb o por
parecer pertenecer a la comunidad del gt
esto viene diciendo que unas nuevas
personas están siendo asesinadas a la
semana sólo porque aparentan o porque
pueden decir y se sienten con la
seguridad de decir en voz alta de que ok
soy gay soy lesbiana soy bisexual
sabes que quiero ser trans sólo por eso
ya otra persona puede decir ok no
mereces vivir
entonces yo me quedé pensando vaya en
mis tres años de secundaria yo pude
haber sido una de esas 594 personas
asesinadas solo porque mis compañeros
creían que yo era lesbiana
y en la actualidad el día de hoy aquí en
este momento delante de ustedes puede
ser una de esas nueve personas
asesinadas sólo por pararme aquí en este
círculo rojo
y decirles soy bisexual
esto no debería pasar es algo inhumano
como se los vengo diciendo y
muchos he conocido a lo largo de mi vida
muchas personas que pertenecen a la
comunidad y en serio son las personas
más maravillosas y amables y lindas que
ustedes se podrían encontrar porque han
sufrido y no quieren que otra persona
sufra
pero las personas se cierran y es como
de no sabes que todas de ser un raro un
monstruo y no puedes pertenecer a
nuestra comunidad
entonces las hacen a un lado y la
sociedad al hacer esto simplemente están
viendo el mensaje de que sabes que tus
ideales tus preferencias tus gustos tus
valores no sean aceptados aquí por lo
tanto puedes irte puedes hacer lo que
quieras pero no vas a pertenecer a
nuestra sociedad una sociedad en la que
seguimos perteneciendo porque al final
del día yo soy como cualquier otro de
los que están aquí presentes o me ven
que tenga 34 brazos no verdad sigo
siendo un humano y sigo teniendo el
derecho a pertenecer en su sociedad a
pesar de los gustos que tenga toda esta
cosa estas violaciones éstos pisoteos de
parte de la sociedad han hecho que
amigos míos que conocidos míos no
encuentren otra salida más que el
suicidio para poder finalmente estar en
paz y esto me deja pensando en qué tipo
de sociedad estamos viviendo para que tú
tengas que recurrir
al suicidio para poder estar en paz
contigo y que las personas que te rodean
también puedan estar en paz y que más
quisiera que mi caso fuera el único y yo
sola para haber pasado por todo esto
pero no esto le pasa al 99% de las
personas que son declaradas de la
comunidad lgtb
y con esto yo también les quiero decir
mi caso puede ser el caso de tu hermana
de tu hija de tu vecina de algún
familiar ser querido de una amistad y si
ella hubiera pasado o él hubiera pasado
por lo que hubiera pasado por lo que yo
estoy pasando
tú qué hubieras hecho te gustaría que la
sociedad le hiciera eso te gustaría que
ella pasara por todo eso sólo por decir
quiero amar a alguien
solo quiero decirles que alguna vez se
han puesto en mis zapatos
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]